bonsoir madame freeland
bonsoir chers
d'abord je tiens à mentionner que vous
avez décidé finalement de présenter
votre mise à jour de façon virtuelle
deux personnes positives à l'aco vide
dans votre équipe est-ce que vous de
votre côté vous allez bien
ah oui merci pour la question et j'ai
pris du test du dépistage et les
résultats tous les deux été négative
mais je pensais que tout le monde doit
prendre des mesures prudentes maintenant
face à la vague de mikron et j'ai décidé
que être dans la chambre des communes
avec tous les députés ce n'était pas une
bon exemple alors je m'excuse très bien
très bien c'est reçu les flat sion donc
est vraiment laid la priorité c'est le
mot don dont tout le monde parle
l'inflation en quoi votre mise à jour
aujourd'hui aide concrètement les
canadiens à vivre mieux avec l'inflation
actuellement
je dirais que la priorité doit être
finir la lutte contre la corrida et la
priorité doit être
continuée dû lutter contre au micro être
prête pour cette nouvelle vague alors
c'est là on peut avoir une prius la
priorité des priorités c'est qu'on doit
dire quelle est la chose la plus
important et je dois dire la chose la
plus importante c'est la lutte contre la
copie mais vous avez raison que la coût
de vie c'est une question importante
pour beaucoup de canadiens et je dirais
quelque chose premièrement et je pense
que vous avez parlé avec des économistes
dans au niveau de votre balade au
concernant l'inflation et la réalité que
c'est une phénomène global et c'est
vraiment important de souligner parce
que pour avoir des mesures ciblées à une
problème on doit comprendre qu'elle
sont des facteurs qui ont créé le
problème c'est une chose importante je
ne disais pas que fait grains de façon
pose la question pour aller directement
les réponses qu'est ce que vous faites
de façon concrète pour aider les
canadiens à faire face à l'inflation
vous avez juste parlé d'une mesure qu'on
a mis en place pour nom pour nos portes
pour les chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est une mesure concrète une autre
chose est important de se rappeler c'est
que les allocations pour les plus
vulnérables les allocations fédérales
sont indexés aux inflation et c'est très
important parce que c'est sans les gens
pour lesquels
l'inflation est le plus difficile les
choses comme la location pour le crg
pour les aînés les choses comme la
location pour les enfants tous ces
allocations sont indexées à l'inflation
d'accord il ya eu une élection il ya
quelques semaines il y avait beaucoup de
promesses notamment la surtaxe pour les
grandes banques
un impôt minimal pour les plus riches
comme départ pour les nouveaux acheteurs
de propriétés ce n'est pas dans la mise
à jour aujourd'hui
est ce que est ce que tout ça est
reporté au budget dans le fond
que l'exercé aujourd'hui n'étaient pas
prévus pour faire toutes ces annonces
madame free run oui précisément
on a eu l'intention de faire
précisément ce que le titre dit essaie
de donner une mise à jour économique et
fiscale aux canadiens et canadiennes
ce qui mise à jour on revient vraiment à
la base de ce qu'est une mise à jour
dans les faits ce n'est pas un budget on
fait simplement mettre à jour les
chiffres
oui précisément et à cause de la lutte
contre la copie qui continue il y à des
dépenses des dépenses important mais des
dépenses très ciblé des dépenses pour
les médicaments des dépenses
pour les ex des dépenses pour les tests
du dépistage des dépenses pour appuyer
les entreprises pendant notre rencontre
la copie mais vous avez raison c'était
vraiment une mise à jour et aux mises à
jour avec des bonnes nouvelles une mise
à jour qui nous dit que la relance
économique du canada est fort que notre
nos résultats sont plus fortes que on a
prévu en avril et plus forte que dans
beaucoup d'économies et qui raison bleus
la nôtre est ce qu'on comprend aussi de
la mise à jour aujourd'hui madame la
ministre que
on va revenir à l'équilibré budgétaire
dans cinq à 2026 27 vous êtes à un
déficit prévu de 13 milliards vous êtes
sur le point d'annoncer une cible de
réduction d'une cible d' équilibre
budgétaire ce qui ferait grand plaisir
d'ailleurs à l'opposition officielle
hommes
merci gérard et
je sais que vous êtes une économiste et
que vous regardez les chiffres très
attentivement je me contente d'être un
journaliste je ne suis pas économiste
mais presque prêt
mais vous avez raison que vraiment on
démontre dans les chiffres dans cette
mise à jour que le ratio dette pib est
plus favorable que on a prévu dans le
budget en avril et que le ratio dette
pib
diminue chaque année c'est une bonne
chose et c'est très important et c'est
important je râle parce que je suis très
heureux et je connais je comprends que
les dépenses que on a fait pendant la
lutte contre la copie de son sérieux je
comprends que les dépenses qu'on fait
maintenant dans la lutte contre le
variant en migrant sans sérieux et pour
cette raison c'est très importante
souligné pour les canadiens que les
dépenses vont s'en vont diminuer et que
on regarde très attentivement les
chiffres pour être certain que les
dépenses est la chose la plus important
le ratio dette pib va continuer de ce
minerai que la mise à jour des montres
je comprends la dette augmente mais la
dette par rapport au pib va baisser
c'est votre projection on verra comment
ça va se passer dans le temps on est à
48 % du pib madame fut l'un d'eux merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci java pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit